[Music]
an animal attack news owes my favorite
topic submitted by five nickels killer
monkeys stoned a 72 year old man to
death with bricks
what killer monkey ball monkeys killer
like it's not like they're purposely
like a little gang trying to [ __ ]
terrorize these monkeys are Apes is
happening no I got these types of
monkeys they purposely like have little
gangs and they [ __ ] with humans are
these guys former baseball players and
they throw fast balls at the bricks
there are monkey gangs though yeah
they're monkey monkeys and that's two
place in India and they have a problem
with these very aggressive monkeys well
they just hug down cuz they're protected
if they're smart enough to throw bricks
that means they're also smart enough to
register it like ogee like threat
tactics yeah yeah you take one of those
monkeys you chop off the [ __ ] head
and you hold it in front of them like oh
my god and then drop it in front of the
children
yeah Walker what protective animals
they're endangered because they act like
this no one likes them why they're
dangerous specie I don't know it's cuz
they're [ __ ] Guba [ __ ] that's why
that's why the government's like there's
only 50 left guys well yeah it would
have been zero they're endangered but do
we want to protect dazzles the [ __ ]
of the jungle and douche bag ass monkeys
I'd be scared I mean they're killer
monkeys that sounds scary yeah so this
man the 72 year old man he was just
collecting dry wood when the monkeys
they've just rained bricks on him Oh
would they get the bricks
yeah after diamond crystal they got them
from like a nearby construction place so
they carried him and they were like you
had to open their teen they were just
chillin for the perfect moment yes that
is a wild you got a [ __ ] snipe these
monkeys dude they get a little too smart
that's the Planet of the Apes [ __ ] right
they're telling you chop off one of the
heads leave it dangling on a tree
I like chimpanzees they'll don't prank
you and they'll laugh well they'll throw
shell and you and run away
what are these monkeys look like they
look at her mind I think what I think
let's get [ __ ] upstairs I love
chimpanzees all these aren't chimpanzees
these are called rhesus monkeys and oh
damn that fool looks like a Japanese
demon
well how did for real though huh are
those the shoulder ones the ones that
hang out on your shoulder you have tea
that looks like if he closes his mouth
that goes past his cheek like chin and
[ __ ] rips through it I know it
probably folds over what looks scariest
bug I wouldn't even want to see lunch
him that's the one you got a [ __ ]
beat up I like how they put the most
threatening picture to so they could get
you extra scared cuz what if it was like
just like picking its friends like hair
and that's the picture you'd be like
either panic you or he's doing a tan or
focus on glass garnish
I never seen monkey teeth like that Yeah
right that looks like a saber-toothed
tiger well baboons have [ __ ] people
oh yeah but who's this dude oh they just
attack he managed it just to attack him
oh he was getting initiated the end
that's what was happening yeah just
watch blood and blood out okay I know
what to do yeah like the family of this
man they want to get justice they're
like these monkeys me and pay for what
they did I have a question for treatment
how do they know that it was monkeys I'm
just assuming he was by himself and then
they walked up on the body that was
vlogging probably that's like a brick
star flying man flying bricks are no
joke though no dude they ended up
arresting the monkeys no you're just
saying like you know the police can't do
anything about it
what the [ __ ] could they do like what
are you gonna do put him in cuffs this
isn't the first time though they they
continue to attack human well maybe
these people should just move out and
leave that area monkey area well what is
that some people in order to combat the
attacks they are employing a group of
monkey catchers known
winger ma'am and so what they do is that
they use these other types of monkeys
are called length lingers that's a
[ __ ] monkey war again yeah yeah
exactly complicated but to interact
directly if I can't [ __ ] them up my
gorilla over here is gonna [ __ ] them up
and I'll you release gorillas and now
those guys are gonna so they're
literally paying another gang to [ __ ] up
another game yeah but the thing is it's
illegal to own a winger so they're like
the Environment Ministry is trying to
crack down on this practice what the
[ __ ] is happening in this part of the
world these dudes are like look like
rivals the opposite way more aggressive
than the other dudes and then like be
and they don't attack humans but the
other ones do and so like but they might
learn to attack humans yeah this has to
be a movie though man yeah this is a
sounds like amazing plot no like they
look like straight arrivals yeah it's
like Union Yang I kind of want to watch
a monkey fight now no I do
No hell I want to watch that monkey
fight dude now like this is like such an
epic ass [ __ ] movie to me right it
really is it could be a sick movie yeah
like this monkeys just like [ __ ] up
humans and they're right behind if he
just sees his big shadow he's like and
you know what too tight like in the
previous in a true story
yeah it's like Planet of the Apes but
then real life yeah the langurs are like
traitors though they're like traitors to
the monkeys they're working for the
humans
you just gotta [ __ ] up these monkeys why
did they care so much about these
[ __ ] monkeys like I I like animals
but once they start attacking humans
it's game over
now you got to [ __ ] them up and they're
doing it on purpose it's not like a
nature like a survival thing yeah
they're actually trying to kill us
so now you tell them all cuz I'd rather
have an animal try to eat me and kill me
yeah cuz I know your purpose but if
you're just trying to kill me is to kill
me [ __ ] them kill you kill for fun you
got to put that [ __ ] pistol in the
[ __ ] mouth of the monkey and just
have it for the other monkey's [ __ ]
around me right now
or that monkeys doing a turn around I'm
holding his childhood in my hands like
this hello oh my god that's a [ __ ]
mental [ __ ] thank you maybe it's cause
like it's just a monkey oh they're
[ __ ] up there like you know territory
and [ __ ] you know they probably see it
as that maybe because what they do is
they break into cars they steal food oh
they're still in my food too
I don't know it's a little extra well I
mean like they don't know crime they're
monkeys yeah but they don't blow it to
the face they're stealing credit cards
and doing identity theft
I know monkey with a mustache and a hat
now who's a [ __ ] Amazon package full
of bananas is going straight to the
jungle issue like who charged a thousand
dollars with the bananas oh my I was
watching some like guerrilla war [ __ ] so
there's like one group of guerrillas and
it's been their territory for a while
they're like a little bit more peaceful
than the small other group of gorillas
and then over time this aggressive
little group of gorillas took over
[ __ ] killed all of them and then now
like babe have you seen gorillas fight
that's pretty nice walking wild have you
seen them they look like Rawling I'm
like that's crazy it's like two
500-pound creatures that could [ __ ]
bench 2,000 pounds yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ]
if I can snap off necks like that should
they have like ever footage of like
gorillas like mangling up a human being
I'm sure dude I'm not sure if it was a
gorilla but I think it was a chimpanzee
but like snap some dudes like arm off or
some [ __ ] there's a lady who got her
face ripped off by all my guys like
literally her face was ripped off you
remember that gorilla that Harambee that
I was just dragging around that kid yeah
that was some wild footage right yeah
yeah nothing just like dragged a little
kid around like it look like he was at
the time of his life though I just like
Coco she looked soft and nice Michael
Jackson met her Oh mr. Rogers Coco's the
sign language the finger tutting would
that [ __ ] gorilla vote if that girl
got mad could have killed everybody in
that real sure they have lost their
[ __ ] mind playing with that [ __ ]
gorilla dude Michael Jackson's monkey
with someone else no Michael Jackson got
to meet Cobo Bobo
chimpanzee oh yeah even imagine if the
gorillas thought a joke was really funny
your [ __ ] arms just broke in the [ __ ]
they can't even understand like a joke
and [ __ ] I think gorillas and
chimpanzees but Jim I think are more
comedic than gorillas just just from
what I see at the zoo because they're
[ __ ] smoking cigarettes no cuz girls
are just like like always chillin and
they'd always look like oh like a baby
having a tantrum but they're so smart
they know that they're locked up yeah
but then the chips they're having a
partay like they're putting dirt on each
other yeah like I saw one chip he was
like [ __ ] chillin and another one came
and put dirt on his head and was like
cracking up and all they do they have
jokes it's scary to me though a little
bit that smart you know it's like
wouldn't there's like that dude who was
doing like magic tricks for the joy and
this monkey was doing that [ __ ] like the
the car disappears like three-year-old
is that well how smart they are like as
a three you remind me of the same thing
like yeah I could totally picture
three-year-old putting dirt on his
friends head and then laughing and [ __ ]
all I know is that gorillas learn sign
language and I can't learn that shoot so
they're already a step above me sure the
only one that's ever known I'm pretty
sure there's another one just like the
famous one yeah is that lady still
around is there named jr. Jane Goodall
oh wait I don't know anymore I think she
died No yeah yeah maybe I mixing her up
with it was another lady too that like
lived with yeah I think that's the one
I'm thinking of as she stole a lot alive
she's still alive baby four years old
wow what an OG I learned about her in
[ __ ] middle school and [ __ ] back in
the day my yeah they made a movie about
it right they sure did day he saw you
need to they did another slacking on
that one I wonder who's gonna play in
the recreation of a Phil did redo a new
one if they're gonna do a biopic about
her who's gonna play there wasn't a need
a younger version for diggin because
they need to do the young oh yeah
probably not
I think Asian she's five for Asian lady
to play
that'd be tight give every man extra be
like okay chill bro we get it we want to
be in a chamber beneath it like constant
to as jane goodall it's time to yellow
watch
[Music]